welcome to Hari salvie's the China where
we discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech products so today
we're taking a look at whether you
should buy the rise in 520 600 X or the
rise in 7 2700 X in mid 2018 but before
we delve into that make sure to hit the
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and PCs so as you
guys already know Rison has brought a
lot of value and it has made building
good gaming PC's for most people much
more affordable and with the launch of
right into he had just been even better
with the rising to not only bring you
better to clock speeds but good stop
coolers for all right into CPUs the
rising 520 600 X and the risin 727 under
X are pretty much the performance kings
of the respective areas the rise in 520
600 X is the top of line hexa-core
processor from AMD and it is pretty much
the perfect sweet spot for gaming and it
delivers more performance than most
gamers really need while the 2700 X is
the perfect chip for people striving to
get a lot of performance and take
advantage of 8 cores for a very good
price however for the people who are
teetering between the 2600 X and the
2700 X the 2700 X is $100 more expensive
so is that hundred dollars worth the 2
extra cores and 4 extra threads and the
performance of the xx assembler X
provides over the 2600 X so first let's
take a look at the specs of both chips
ask for the 2600 X it has 6 cores 12
threads with the base frequency of 3.6
Secours and a max turbo frequency of 4.2
goo Hertz and asked for the 2700 X that
has eight cores and 16 threads with the
base frequency of 3.7 gigahertz the max
turbo frequency at four point three
gigahertz and on top of this the 2600 X
has a TDP of 95 watts
while the 2700 X has a TDP about ten
more watts at 105 watts
lastly the 26 cortex costs $220 while 27
rx cost $320 so that's all the technical
details of these two chips but how did
those technical details translate to
real world more
well asked for gaming performance I
looked at very many benchmarks online
for the two chips and pretty much all
benchmarks clearly show that there
really is no difference in gaming
between 2600 X and the 2700 X the FPS is
pretty much identical between the two
chips only 2 to 3 FPS difference in most
modern games at 1080p and 1440p in some
more CPU intensive games that difference
does grow to 10 frames per second but
that's still very negotiable so as a
result as forgiving performance the two
chips are pretty much identical however
if you look at productivity performance
the story is quite different for
programs such as Premiere Pro After
Effects blender and things of that
nature
the 27 rx has a clear lead over 2600 X
at about 20 to 30% faster times and
finally ask for Windows performance both
ships can easily crush Windows and the
experience is pretty much the same
something else to consider before
choosing which of these CPUs to buy is
the future of both CPUs right now most
modern games aren't really designed to
take advantage of 8 cores and that is
why the difference between the 2700 X
and the 2600 X in most games are pretty
much nothing and another major point is
that in most modern games these CPUs are
not the bottleneck and the GPU is the
actual bottleneck so that's why the
performance is pretty much identical
between the two chips however in the
future as more modern GPUs like the xi
history from nvidia and AMD na b come
out on top of getting more optimized for
hard core con cpus the difference in FPS
between the 2700 x and the 2600 x but
most likely get much bigger so ask for
longevity the 27 X now let's say in five
years we'll definitely be able to handle
the modern games much better than the
2600 X will be able to handle them so
that is definitely something to keep in
mind as well finally the last thing to
consider before choosing warranty is
CPUs is considering the future to the
abuser coming out very soon and whether
they will make these CPUs oppositely
like what happened with the 7700 okay
so ask for AMD with their third
generation of CPUs they're having a huge
upgrade because they're going on to the
seven and a metre process and they may
even bring 12 or 16 cores on to the
mainstream platform of risin three in
the third generation on top of that
there are very many rumors suggesting
that the next series of rising CPUs will
be able to overclock all the way to 5
gigahertz so if you guys can wait for
another nine months until the next
release of Rison yeah I really recommend
if you do so because I feel like there
is going to be a huge upgrade with the
next series of right and CPUs however if
you really need to upgrade right now
then which CPU should you buy well this
really comes down to two things what are
you going to mainly be using your PC for
and how long are you going to wait
before upgrade your PC once more if you
mainly use your PC for gaming then I
really recommend that you guys just go
ahead and get the 2600 X B the 2600 X
has more than enough performance for
most all modern games and it's going to
be a while before games really take
advantage of eight core CPUs so 2600 X
is more than enough for the next couple
of years really the only reason that you
would get 27 Ardex for a gaming CPU is
if you're not going to upgrade your
appear for a while like around 5 years
or longer then 27 X may make sense but
otherwise you guys should just save your
money by getting 2600 X and use that
money to get some other better PC parts
like a better GPU or an SSD if you guys
are going to use your PC mostly for
productivity reasons and you're very
serious about what you do whether it's
video editing or graphic design and I
really recommend you guys just to spend
extra money and get the 2,700 X
especially if you're planning to use it
for quite a while because 27 X is just
so much better when it comes down to
productivity and you will be able to see
a difference day to day and it'll just
make your life much better so I really
recommend that you guys just spend extra
money and get to 2700 X if you plan to
use your PC mostly for productivity but
really I think the best thing for
everyone is just the weight Verizon
third generation space there is going to
be a huge upgrade with that generation
Rison 2 is just a simple upgrade over
aizen 1 while rising 3 is going to go on
to a whole new process so I really
recommend
you guys great for the third generation
rising if you can however if you really
need a CPU right now then something else
to consider
instead of getting a 2600 X or the 2700
X it's getting a rise in three CPU right
now and then upgrading it later on like
in a year or two to 3,700 X or 4700 X or
something crazy like that which will be
on the seventh animator process maybe
even have 12 or 16 cores and may even be
able to overclock all the way to 5
gigahertz so here's the verdict if you
guys can't wait for third generation
risin yeah I really recommend you guys
just do that however if you really need
to upgrade right now and you mainly use
your PC for gaming and recommend you
guys just go for 2600 X if you mainly
use your PC for productivity or if
you're not going to upgrade for awhile
like 5 years then I recommend you guys
check out 2700 X finally if you want to
get a third generation rise in CPU but
you also need a CPU right now then
something to consider is getting a rise
in three CPU right now and then upgrade
later on because AMD is very lenient
with their backwards compatibility and
you can use all your same parts right
now like your motherboard with the next
series of CPUs from AMD so that's
definitely something to keep in mind as
well but that's just what I think how do
you guys feel about this which option do
you think is better the 2600 X or the
2700 X or do you think you should wait
for a third generation rising make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and here's as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts
obviously if you guys like this video
then make sure double-eye key and hit
that subscribe button if you guys like
to see more videos just like this one
well until next time bye
[Music]